daily wire reports Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis announced Wednesday evening on
Twitter that he's running for president
United States to Santa's filed paperwork
with the Federal Election Commission
earlier in the afternoon released his
initial official launch video at 6 PM
eastern time on the platform
which glitched initially as hundreds of
thousands of users attempted to tune in
uh DeSantis said in a video our border
is a disaster crime infests our cities
the federal government makes it harder
for families to make ends meet when the
president flounders but the client is a
choice of success is attainable and
freedom is worth fighting for
um desant has also joined a special
event on Twitter with the platform's
owner Elon Musk which musk said received
so much interest that it crashed the
event due to the servers being
overloaded
the servers are straining somewhat musk
said at one point as 700 000 people
logged into the event and um so that was
kind of the story DeSantis announced
they did their Twitter event Twitter
spaces
uh it was the biggest Twitter spaces
event ever crashed the servers causing
some headaches and hiccups early on now
of course desantis's opponents uh his
critics both those on the left and in
Trump's Camp tried to spin this as like
a huge disaster the fact that the uh
that the servers were having trouble is
a huge disaster and
um I saw someone tweet that the DeSantis
campaign is over it's over because of
this it's done it's finished
is that true well obviously not I mean
it's absurd and this is this is one of
the reasons why I dread these political
Seasons campaign Seasons because we have
to deal with this sort of thing all the
time you know people taking every little
thing that a politician does and trying
to blow it as as out of proportion as
much as possible say this is the end
this is going to be it and meanwhile as
I'm constantly reminding people
okay
by the time
the people have a memory you know in in
American society these days in in
Western Society generally the average
memory is about 14 and a half seconds I
think we're down to
so anything that happened before 14 and
a half seconds ago it doesn't matter if
it happened months ago it might as well
have not happened okay it might as well
have happened in the Middle Ages
so by the time the primaries start the
idea that anyone remembers all you know
I was going to vote for DeSantis but
that uh that campaign announcement was a
little glitchy I'm not sure about that
uh it's just not gonna happen primary
voters aren't going to be making their
decisions based on whether a Twitter
spaces event months earlier went well or
or anything else but this is this is
just this is true in general
it's like most of what happens right now
doesn't matter for for any of these guys
what matters is what happens directly
before the voting actually starts
because that's the only thing anyone's
going to be thinking about
um
and the I think the the one thing that
we take from this
like the actual event itself doesn't
matter what he said doesn't matter
politically doesn't matter because again
nobody's gonna remember nobody cares
nobody remembers any campaign launch
announcement you know
um there might be
Donald Trump coming down the escalator
like that's an image that people
remember but as far as what's actually
said and all that it's it's it's rare
that anyone really remembers that or
cares at least I'll say that
um the one takeaway from this is that
there was a lot of interest there's a
lot of interest to crash the servers and
uh that's what matters
um what we know is that if any other
non-trump Republican
if any other non-trump Republican
nominee did the same kind of event
and did a Twitter spaces event and
probably they'll all do one at some
point
they aren't going to crash the servers
right Nikki Haley or Tim Scott or Mike
Pence you're not gonna have 700 000
people trying to trying to get in on the
action here what Mike Pence has to say
only DeSantis can do that and only Trump
can do that
those are the two Republicans in the
race
uh and probably the two Republicans
period in the on the political scene
who could potentially crash the servers
because so many people want to hear what
they say and that's why they're the only
two who really matter in this race
and for Trump this is this is the first
time that he's facing a primary
Challenger who actually draws that kind
of attention and interest uh he's never
had that before uh there was nobody else
in 2016 that anyone cared about or was
paying attention to Trump sucked up all
the oxygen in the room he still sucks up
a lot of the oxygen but not all of it
and part of the reason is that the left
hates DeSantis
uh he arguably even more than they hate
Trump they despise him because of the
policies he's put in place in Florida
they hate him for all the reasons that
many of us like him and this again is
something that Trump hasn't really dealt
with before so it'll be interest
interesting our country might be headed
in the wrong direction but prageru
videos could help save the future of
America prageru makes educational
pro-american content that's been
changing people's minds for over a
decade their impact is pivotal in these
times my friends at prageru are reaching
millions of people with their
educational videos every day but they
have a long way to go you can help
Prager you reach thousands more people
by joining Club five for just five
dollars or more per month go to
prageru.com Club five now to join your
gift will ensure that prageru has the
support it needs to be here for the Long
Haul what are you waiting for you can
join a movement with thousands of fellow
Patriots in the fight to save America
you'll receive a free prageru bumper
sticker plus an e-book of scripts from
prageru's five-minute videos when you
join Club five today that's prageru.com
Club five today you know the first step
in uh growing up and being a real man is
getting off your parents phone plan
getting your own cell phone plan gives
you a sense of Independence and
responsibility it's a step towards
becoming more self-sufficient by paying
for your own finances you learn how to
budget and manage your money there are a
ton of cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into these contracts then tack on
hidden fees at any chance they get
that's why I'm a big fan of pure talk
there are no contracts no hassles you
can cancel at any time it's very simple
Pure Talk is also giving you a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy phone
when you sign up for the 55 per month
unlimited plan plus hotspot today they
use the same Nationwide networks as
major carries so you get all the same
coverage that you do but a lot cheaper a
lot easier switching over to Pure Talk
is so easy you can make the switch keep
your cell phone keep your phone number
with their Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service that they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee so go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Walsh just say 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
what does that mean
you know there are people saying that
this primary between Trump and Sanders
will be good it'll be good for both guys
and for the right generally because iron
sharpens iron and all of that and and I
would agree okay I would agree that this
is good
if
if it means that Trump and DeSantis are
going to try to outmaneuver each other
to the right if this is a primary that
ends with both men going farther to the
right becoming even more conservative
than great if they're trying to out
conservative each other and taking
positions that are that are that are
ever more to the right then I say that
works out well for us that's great
whoever wins in the end it's good for us
but my fear is that it won't go that way
and instead you're going to have some in
the Trump Camp who go to the left we've
already seen some of that happening with
the Trump camps siding with Disney for
instance coming out against the Bud
Light boycott and so on
and if that happens then we have a
fracturing of the movement with part of
it going to the left and that would be a
very bad thing no matter who wins it's
just bad and and my main concern is the
conservative movement it's it's the work
we're trying to do in the culture
it's why I led the show today with the
target boycott and now not Ron DeSantis
and his uh presidential announcement
because I think that other stuff matters
more
um and that's what I care about yeah I
support the scientists but if Trump wins
then I'll vote for him in the general
the main thing I care about is the fight
in the culture at least at least
staying United on the issues
so that's what it comes down to for me
right if
if we can
uh stay United on the issues but then
yell at each other about which
politician is better great that's funny
you know that's fun we can have fun with
that that's perfectly fine who cares
about that
my fear is that we lose the unity on the
issues
and you start having people saying well
uh I don't know if I don't agree with
this anymore because you know because in
an attempt to pull some kind of
political maneuver and stay loyal to one
politician or another they they start
abandoning their their position on the
issues and if that happens
um
then it becomes catastrophic
for everybody involved
just so just for example here's a Laura
Loomer is a big time Trump supporter um
interviewing some Trump supporters who
are picketing outside of the DeSantis
campaign kickoff event
so so far that's fine you like the other
guy you don't like this guy so you're
out there you know sticking up for your
guy perfectly fine
but listen to what is said in this
interview
I'm here outside of the Four Seasons
Resort in Miami on Brickell Avenue with
Maurice from blacks for Trump so what
are you doing here today outside of
desantis's uh presidential announcement
I'm here to destroy DeSantis because
he's a bastard from hell
I'm here to let uh him know that I
helped you only because Trump asked us
to actually go out and help we stopped
Barbara Grant from cheating on you and
Rubio and and a few others and this is
how you repay Trump shows me that you
are a traitor no good bastard from hell
so what I'm gonna do is make sure that
you don't win and that everybody knows
that you're a rhino Republican racist
that's right because those are the races
Republicans and deplorables are not
racist the ones that make everybody look
racist is you damn rhinos like you
Ronnie so I'm against the racist rhinos
for Ronnie
I first of all the stuff about he
betrayed Trump he's this little Trump
um
nobody cares about that that's it's
ridiculous first of all the idea that he
that he owes
what exactly is that the idea here the
Trump has owed the presidency that that
DeSantis owes him something and can't
run for president I mean it's it's
absurd but it's also that's not
that can't be the message okay Trump is
very powerful when he's talking about
the people and he's and he's sticking up
for the people and he's and he's making
uh the the people that have been
forgotten by the corporate media and by
the system and he's making them feel
seen and heard and like we actually care
about you
that is Trump's superpower but when the
message becomes well it's not about you
guys it's about it's about Trump and we
have to do this for his sake and to
defend him
that's not nearly as powerful you're not
going to get people to go into the polls
to Def it's like go to the polls to
defend the people not to defend this
individual
but putting that aside
um the Rhonda Santos is a racist
they're throwing the racist he's a
racist
oh the the real Republicans aren't
um
this is a this is a leftist attack and
this is it's also completely ridiculous
and false it's a full-on leftist attack
and criticism is an attack from the left
all the way from the far left
and this is the kind of thing I'm
worried about not that this one clown
standing outside the event represents
any kind of larger group
but it's the kind of thing I'm worried
this is this is the kind of thing we
don't want to see where we scramble over
to the left he's the racist so yeah you
support whoever you want
but what we can't do is support People
based on this um
lame leftist these lame leftist tactics
they uses the word Rhino there I don't
think he understands even what he's
saying but Rhino but by Rhino we mean
kind of like fake squishy milk toast
conservatives that is fake squishy milk
toast conservatism right there what you
just heard from him Dems are the real
racists we're not racist you are
um
so that can't be the tactic
it's not gonna work
you know it's not gonna work certainly
not going to work in the general and all
it's going to do is is rip the the
movement apart
that'll do it for this portion shows and
move over to the members block you
become a member today by using Code
walls to check out for two months for
you on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed